something that popped up late last night
that has direct relevance to the
national football league
and the houston texans a lawsuit
supposedly filed by a prominent
houston lawyer on behalf of a masseuse
who according to the lawyer tony busby
contends that texans quarterback
deshaun watson went too far during
a massage now we haven't seen the
lawsuit the lawyer claims and he spoke
to fox 26 in houston
that it was filed desean watson has
addressed it on social media
tony busby has addressed it on social
media
i want to see the actual civil complaint
i want to see the paperwork that
initiates the process
because look and we'll talk about some
of the the strange
facts surrounding this
lawyer's connection to the texans yeah
different reasons to look at this and
wonder what's going on but chris
once there is a document appropriately
filed
and stamped and the process initiated
in civil court in texas whether state or
federal once that document's filed
there's a piece of litigation that must
be dealt with and the allegations that
are reduced to writing and
signed by a duly licensed attorney who
presumably would like to keep his or her
license those allegations must
be dealt with in a process that
is very simple there's a complaint the
complaint
is answered at some point the judge gets
involved and
issues a scheduling order there's a
discovery process where people are
questioned documents are exchanged it
it hinges in many respects on how
aggressive or creative the lawyers are
in seeking the information sometimes
you get a creative and smart lawyer
involved you put the other side in a
corner
and there's no way out it's a chess
match and then you go to trial
eventually if the case doesn't settle
and this is something that can last a
year two years it just depends on how
quickly
the justice system moves and how
motivated the parties are but once this
is
filed it's real yeah now i say that
because we've yet to see any evidence
that has been filed
right but once it is filed it's real and
once it is filed it has to be dealt with
and desean watson chris decided last
night to deal with it by addressing it
disclosing it that's how i became aware
of it yeah disclosed it on social media
that's a
a daring and calculated ploy to take the
initiative from a pr standpoint but the
bottom line is this
we haven't seen the lawsuit once the
lawsuit's filed it is real and it has to
be dealt with
and no amount of public denials by
desean watson will make it go away
it has to be dealt with and made to go
away within the confines of the legal
system
and that's a process that isn't resolved
by simply saying
i disagree with these allegations
there's a lot more to it than that
no i mean obviously there is a lot more
to it and i want to rush to judgment on
either side here or anything like that
but i mean
you know again deshaun watson i don't
blame him for getting out in front of
this thing a little bit
to just put out a statement like that
you know either way
his name is going to be smeared here
over the next 24 48 hours so
he's letting it be known where he's
where he stands on the situation
how he sees it and you know good for him
in that
you know aspect but but again like you
said we'll see where this goes it does
just
it it it smells fishy and i'm not trying
to be insensitive or anything like that
i'm i'm not but i i don't i don't know
there are fishing let's
yeah there's fishy signals here that's
all right right
but and here and here's the reality at
the end of the day is there
a masseuse who is claiming and will
testify under oath
yeah that there was something that
happened we don't know that
yet we don't know what's going on here
until there's an
actual lawsuit filed and once the
lawsuit's filed it doesn't mean you
accept as true
the allegations that were made that just
is the first step in framing out the
issue that goes forward and there's all
shapes and sizes and sorts of civil
lawsuits whether it's
sexual assault whether it's breach of
contract whether it's wrongful
termination of employment whether it's a
business dispute between two major
companies the civil justice system is
used
for all sorts of things but once that
document's filed
the system doesn't care who's
telling the truth or isn't they'll
figure that out at the end they got a
process for that it's a jury trial
the point is once it's filed once it's
real it's not something that
just magically goes away look at what
antonio brown's been dealing with since
september of 2000
9 the lawsuit for civil uh
the civil lawsuit for sexual assault and
rape in florida and
you know people think that your only
avenue
when something like this happens is the
criminal justice system chris
you don't have to take it to sure
the police you don't have to try to get
someone prosecuted
you can pursue this route instead now
create skepticism well that seems like
what happened
why didn't you go yeah why didn't why
didn't you go to yeah why did we have so
why didn't you go to the police you're
going straight to court yeah we don't
know any of the
specific allegations yet right but but
deshawn watson's the one who chose
to put this on our radar screen that to
me is significant yeah well i think you
know he probably
realized he's a pretty smart guy from
what we know and
have seen of him in the past to he knew
he knows he's a franchise quarterback
he's one of the stars of the nfl
and he probably realized that this was
about to become a story whatever else
and he's going to let
you know his side out a little bit but i
mean you know again
like when do you expect the the
paperwork to be filed after something
like this do you think it's already in
the process here
at this point well the way the lawyer
spoke in the
comments that he gave to fox 26 it
suggested in the headline on the fox 26
website
didn't imply it said the lawsuit was
filed
yeah so it's a public document that it
should be out it should be available
it's all popped up just before midnight
last night first order of business for
me as soon as we're done today
try to get my hands on this document and
see what it says or
confirm that it hasn't been filed if
there is no such filing we don't even
know the name
of the person making the accusation
sometimes these cases are filed under
a jane doe or a john doe type of a name
for privacy reasons
but that that's to me you know i've got
a lot of questions
that yeah i'd like to try to resolve
after we're done i just want to see that
there's a lawsuit and i want to see what
it says
right but like the next thing i just
wanted to ask you because i figure
you know a lot better than me for sure
you know how
how rare or not rare is it where
you get a case like this right maybe the
suit hasn't been filed yet or anything
and
you know the lawyer the accuser make a
you know demand for money before they
even go to that prop like
how rare or very common it's very very
common to always go to the guy
hey here's what we're going to do we're
going to file this pay us this money or
or we will file it that that so that's
that's commonplace with these type of
things
i wouldn't say always yeah but it's
there's nothing unusual about
the comment made by deshaun watson that
the the the plaintiff's lawyer claims
this isn't about money but before filing
suit he made a baseless six-figure
settlement demand which i quick
quickly rejected um yeah that
is not uncommon now if it was six
fig and it's some people looking at
saying well if it's only six figure how
big of a deal can it be well we don't
know what the factual allegations are
you don't just make seven and
eight-figure settlement demands
willy-nilly right you you want to have
it based on
something but it's not uncommon to make
a demand letter that's one of the first
things they teach in law school how to
write a a demand letter to inform
a defendant or that defendant's lawyer
that there is
a potential piece of litigation that
will be filed and
it it can be avoided if the case is
resolved now
there's a fine line chris between
that right and the concept of extortion
and in many ways
that entire pre-suit process of
negotiating or trying to negotiate a
settlement
is legal extortion we're in the period
of legal tampering that is legal
extortion there are claims you can make
there are things you can say now you
better be ready to back it up
you can't just say hey i'm going to sue
you on behalf of my client if you don't
pay us a bunch of money
and then there's no client right or no
lawsuit right then you got a problem so
uh you're on thin ice if you don't have
something to back that up but
presumably there there will be a lawsuit
if there's no lawsuit ever filed then
this tony busby's got himself one hell
of a mess
and again that's one of the questions i
have has this lawsuit been filed and why
would he create the impression that it
has been
if it hasn't been uh and sometimes what
happens is the more
successful a lawyer is the more
established the more powerful the more
people the lawyer knows you can get a
little
drunk on that you can get a little
reckless with that and you can maybe
take some liberties because you think
you're untouchable or no one's going to
mess with you or
you can get and i'm not saying he's done
that it's just part of my curiosity yeah
that's part of my
very very curious how curious about the
how good is the relationship between
busby and you know the owners of the
texans i'm curious of that i mean that
that's
that's i mean there is some common there
right uh or some common place there i
just i wonder about all these
things and again i don't want to sound
insensitive in any way if desean watson
did something then you know damn him and
he needs to be better and i'm not going
to just forgive him i'm not saying that
but it just seems weird
we're a long way from knowing whether he
did yeah a long way from knowing whether
he did or didn't do anything yeah we
don't even know who the person is
yeah that that's making the claim but um
the the connection with the the
lawyer and and the mcnairs
tony busby was or is a neighbor of the
mcnairs and seven years ago tony busby
put up this big billboard trying to get
the texans to draft johnny manziel and
he's actually
proud of that i it i see like i don't
know that i'd be proud of advocating
that anyone draft johnny
manziel seven years after the fact but
you know look
people are suggesting that some way
somehow the texans and the lawyer are in
cahoots yeah
and and and if you're trying to keep
desean watson
i don't know that this is the way to do
it no right
definitely but but if you're convinced
that desean watson's never going to play
for you again and you're pissed
off about it yes i'm not saying that
they would deliberately do it
but if you've got somebody out there
that feels this friendship
kinship with the mcnairs and and all
somebody just happens to trip
into his office making this allegation
you
you may be more inclined to embrace it
because hey deshaun watson has made it
his mission
to crap on the texans and and get out of
town and
this is our way of exacting some
vengeance before he's even traded and i
don't say
r meaning the texans are directly
involved but this tony busby may think
that that he's doing them some sort of a
right of a a favor
that they may not want because they
haven't traded him yet you know
this is the kind of thing that can
affect his trade values like hey tony we
appreciate the effort we appreciate that
you care about us but you know we still
haven't traded this guy
let's not go guns blazing after deshaun
watson until we have a deal in place to
trade deshaun watson so
there's a clumsiness to it if there is
any sort and i'm not saying there is
part of what we're going to try to
figure out
any sort of direct or indirect
connection it's clumsy
and it's misguided and it doesn't
necessarily help the texans
because now whoever would trade for
deshaun watson
and would be making this decision in a
compressed time frame where you got
other quarterback options for 2021
right now they got something else they
got to deal with they got to get down to
the bottom of this rabbit hole and
figure out what's there or what's not
there with this litigation because if
you trade for deshaun watson
you're buying whatever this becomes and
right now we don't know what it's going
to become no we don't know what it's
going to become and these are the kind
of things that scare teams away and do
that
you know i i mean it just it just it's
crazy the timing of all of it
you know desean watson uh
just again not saying that just knowing
a guy or the appearance or meeting him
but man i just it just i have never
met a nicer guy and that doesn't mean
i've met other nice guys that fooled me
before i understand
i understand i mean yes i think here's
what i'm trying to say is there is
absolutely nothing that either of us
have heard about or
seen or anything exactly any any reason
to believe
that he would do something like this
that's a fair comment to make
okay and that comment has been made
about others in the past
right who have ultimately been proven to
have done something they shouldn't have
done that's right so
we don't know we're in no position to
know
i want to see the lawsuit yeah i want to
know what the allegation is
and the problem is and what happens is
when you're the one who's been sued
there's a frustration that immediately
kicks in because you want you you
especially if you know you did nothing
wrong right you
number one want to shout it from the
rooftops which he's done and number two
you want to hit fast forward you want
this to be over you want your name to be
cleared and it gets frustrating because
you don't get your name quickly cleared
definitely not a process that you submit
to
and you have to accept the fact that
until we get to the end
there's going to be this cloud and the
problem is the court of public opinion
you're gonna have people
who jump to conclusions that's the
biggest thing well the allegations been
made it must be true
yeah or you have to believe every
allegation that's ever made until
there's proof to the contrary well no
that's not how the system works and and
so
this is a problem for watson it's a
problem for the texans
it's a problem for anyone that wants to
trade for him and you know
the league has a personal conduct policy
that i know sometimes it
it feels like enforcing sometimes it
doesn't feel like enforcing
the consistency isn't there the way that
it should be
but this is something that they can't
ignore either to the extent that they
are sitting back and waiting to see what
happens with the
antonio brown sexual assault claim
investigation litigation they they need
to at a minimum
be gathering information and monitoring
this they they they have the same
questions that we have yeah let's see
the lawsuit let's see what the
allegations are
and uh one thing that flowed from the
ray rice incident from seven years ago
chris
the nfl will set up its own parallel
track of investigation
and and discipline if it
deems that discipline is necessary part
of it too is how motivated
is this alleged victim will she
cooperate with the nfl the way ezekiel
elliott's
alleged victim actual victim whatever
the proper term is the nfl decided he
did something that the court system
never decided he did
but that's part of this too and when and
when the nfl decides to create its own
in-house justice system
and a claim like this is made the
question becomes are you activating
nfl your in-house justice system that's
a fair and obvious question given the
things the nfl's done in the past in
cases
that are like this one yeah i mean i i
would expect
you know like you they're gonna wait and
see how this unfolds a little bit
see some of the paperwork gather a
little more evidence but man
i mean the texans what an off-season i
don't know what to say
you know i mean holy cow just total
soap opera you know page six dysfunction
it's just one thing after another it
really is it's it's unbelievable
and you know the other thing too the the
thing that
where i think deshaun watson and again
you know
if we see that he's guilty of this
you'll you'll hear me you know stick it
to him if that's the case but yeah i
know
i know but i'm just saying premature to
even suggest okay well either way
his name will never be cleared from
these things that's where that's where
it's tough for football players and a
quarterback especially it'll never be
cleared
there's going to be some people that'll
have their mind name made
yeah time out time out time out yeah if
there is something
fishy if the fishy sense like just this
whole this is weird this is odd yeah if
there's anything
there and he's represented by capable
and competent and smart lawyers there
are devices for exposing
that it's all a load of crap there are
devices for doing it yeah right cheap
for him to do it he's gonna be paying
somebody by the hour to do it
right but we don't know where the facts
are gonna take us
to a certain extent you just gotta sit
back and see where the facts take you
and presumably tony busby has
someone who sufficiently convinced him
that something happened now the problem
is maybe he's too close to this maybe
he's upset with deshaun watson maybe
he's trying to help the mcnairs again
these are a bunch of maybes
sometimes your judgment gets clouded if
you're thinking hey i got a potential
tiger by the tail here
right and you don't and you don't you
don't apply the same
scrutiny and level of questioning
and you don't trust that little voice
it's telling you something's not right
here so sometimes things get glossed
over
and then once the case moves forward
let's say once your client ends up being
questioned under oath
and it's all one big giant mess of
the person running around in circles and
not answering questions and it doesn't
hold together
that's when you know you got a problem
so these are all things to be determined
but there are ways chris
there are ways to to depending upon
where the facts take us
there are ways desean watson could
expose this as being
a big sham we just again this is just
one of the possibilities on the radar
screen
it could be 100 true it could be 100
false
and it could be 100 false plus the
product of some
some effort with improper motive to make
desean watson look bad
and with the right counsel and the right
approach
you can show that it was all baloney
that in theory that could happen all
right well we'll see where it goes
yeah that that's all i got to say i
don't have anything more to dive into it
unless there's some other interesting
angles you want to talk about and i'll
listen and ask you questions but i
i i get scared talking about these
subjects sometimes i'm not gonna lie
i mean pull back the curtain i'm yeah i
get scared i don't know what the hell to
say sometimes i don't want to get myself
in trouble get you in trouble or
anything
you you you're doing fine you've learned
all right i've learned and uh
you ain't getting me in trouble i'm not
a ventriloquist you you own your own
words there christopher
but you're 40 now you know how to do
these things you know how to handle
yourself you've learned
um but uh yeah look and it's it's a
serious topic we had the brief
conversation before the show started we
want to talk about football but
how can we ignore something i know that
desean watson himself
injected it into my consciousness
i didn't know anything about this until
i see deshaun watson's tweet
so he wants us addressing it he wants us
sharing his statement which we did
and i'd like to think he appreciates
that we have been fair and even-handed
in trying to explain
how this works and i can understand the
frustration he's feeling today
because he would like to be able to go
to the end of the
process and have the ruling that he did
nothing wrong
if he truly believes in his heart that
he did nothing wrong
all right i got a lot of conspiracy
theories on that one that just it's
you know yeah listen there's reason
to have questions right and those
questions need to be explored and i
guarantee you
i'm going to explore all of them and i'm
going to start as soon as we sign off
in about 1 hour and 39 minutes from now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports